voici m'aide et me baisse et jo je
travaille sur un roman c'est l'histoire
de ma vie et mes soeurs fait court et
piquant et si le personnage principal
est une fille arrangez-vous pour qu'elle
soit mariée à la fin je veux être
artiste à rome et devenir le meilleur
peintre du monde ce n'est pas ce que tu
veux tu aussi joe devenir un célèbre
écrivain si mais ça fait tellement
vulgaire quand elle le dit nos filles
ont tendance à faire des sottises toi
moi aussi voici meg et me baisse et john
bien réussir par moi-même à personne ne
réussit jamais seul
surtout pas de femme tu dois faire un
bon mariage mais vous vous n'êtes pas
mariée pendant dix mois je suis riche
tu en voudriez vous danser avec moi
c'est impossible j'ai brûlé ma robe et
mec m'a dit de ne pas bouger pour que
personne ne s'en aperçoive
je crois que j'ai trouvé comment faire
à
jo est une cause perdue l'espoir de la
famille reposent sur toi je pense que
nous avons la faculté de choisir qui on
aime ce n'est pas quelque chose qui nous
tombe dessus
je doute que les poètes partage cet avis
il n'y a qu'à partir maintenant je
vendrai mes histoires je mets toi tu
devrais être actrice et faire carrière
sur les planches
ce n'est pas parce que mes rêves sont
différents détient qu'ils sont moins
bons je t'aime depuis que je te connais
jo c'est plus fort que moi ce serait un
désastre si le soir il parle des autres
on serait malheureux jojoy chez sobeys
grèce
[Musique]
une nouvelle pièce de mademoiselle jomaa
les femmes ont un cerveau et une âme pas
seulement un coeur je veux être célèbre
au riad ils sont ambitieuse et
talentueuse pas uniquement belle j'en ai
assez sondés tellement inquiet
d'entendre dire que les femmes ne sont
faites que pour l'amour
j'en ai par dessus la tête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certaines nature sans trop fier pour
s'incliner
bon alors et les boues ski
[Musique]